a 6 15 on your tuesday morning time to
rise and shine
so this is where we share stories with
you to help get your day started on a
positive note we say good morning to las
vegas now host mercedes martinez joining
us live
from her mania over at the mix 94.1
studios hey good morning mercedes
good morning nate it is so great to see
you this morning hoping to put a smile
on your face
well so this morning i understand we're
talking about that old showbiz saying
don't work with kids or animals
yeah apparently that holds true for tv
news reporters too
check out what happened when a weather
reporter tried to do this live
shot from a busy section of moscow
the reporter had just started her live
weather report when a golden retriever
came out of nowhere took off with the
microphone but she was able to chase
down the pup and eventually
get that good boy some good head rubs
and some chin scratches
all right so i guess the forecast there
for moscow mercedes was cloudy with a
chance
of uh of my mic being stolen
oh i think mercedes is frozen boy yeah
obviously he's a good boy and everything
turned out okay
yeah i just uh when it's bring your dog
to work day be careful about that you
never know what could happen into
in the channel a studios over there yes
we are very careful we also want to make
sure no microphones are injured in the
production of the show
exactly mercedes always a pleasure
talking with you we'll let you get back
to the radio gig but we'll see you
this afternoon here on las vegas now
sounds great thanks jay
peace out all right let's see
over time here i think nate and bianca
part of it is
that microphone flag is very colorful
and it's enormous
i think it probably looked like a dog
toy yeah fahren even though i
if i'm you know rover i would have made
the same mistake
and where's the owner at you know the
owner is like oh there's the toy right
there it's in that weather person's
hands
well for all we know that is the weather
person's dog oh
okay we don't know it was his debut she
was just trying to find
some way to tie it all in no we're on to
you we're on deep
if any of us spoke russian we would
probably have a much better idea of what
was going on there yeah dasvidanya
no kazentei i've been at
live shots before where a cat climbed
all the way up my my coat and like
slapped me in the face i i need to see
it i don't believe it
tweeted it out thousand years ago i got
slapped in the face by a cat at all
instagram story john langler let's go
sure
we want to see proof